Donc aujourd'hui, les 10 décisions que
les gens de 50 ans regrettent de ne pas
avoir prises à 20 ans. Donc si tu as 20
ans que c'est une méchante bonne vidéo à
regarder live. Donc sans plus tarder, on
va commencer. Donc
la donnée qui change tout à 50 ans,
c'est l'âge moyen où les gens commencent
à vraiment savoir qui ils sont. Ça c'est
Carl Gustave Jung de qui parle du
processus d'individualisation. Je pense
qu' un livre là-dessus euh qui dit c'est
la l'âge moyen où c'est que les gens
connaissent, ils commencent vraiment à
connaître qui ils sont parce que toute
leur vie ils ont fait tellement
d'expériences qui ont appris à se
connaître puis à 50 ans c'est l'âge
c'est que ils commencent à vraiment
savoir qui sont mais l'affaire qui est
beau là-dedans, c'est que ça c'est en
fonction de ton expérience que tu as de
des choix que tu as pris précédemment.
C'est ça qu'on va voir aujourd'hui pour
pas que ça arrive à 50 ans que tu v une
crise la crise de la quarantaine qui
appelle que là tu fais un crime. J'ai
pas pris des décisions pour moi
finalement pu tout ça puis là tu
commences à te questionner sur qui tu es
vraiment. Donc
le problème ton cerveau est en guerre et
tu le sais pas. Donc l'entreprise
psychique donc sans structure consciente
ton esprit derrière vers la facilité le
stimulus rapide puis l'impulsion. Donc
si tu prends pas le temps d'écrire
vraiment, de faire du journaling, de
prendre ton temps de savoir qu'est-ce
que tu veux vraiment dans ta vie puis à
quoi tu pense, à qu c'est quoi tes
envies, c'est quoi tes apprentissages,
c'est quoi pourquoi toi tu es là, si tu
te questionnes pas, ben ça va être le tu
tu tu vas juste penser à 10000 affaires,
tu vas être attiré vers toutes les
choses qui sont distractives. tu vas
aller au bord, tu vas aller tu vas
t'ater vers les filles, tu vas être
complètement distrait parce que tu es
pas focus sur à te questionner pourquoi
toi tu es sur terre, tu sais. Puis c'est
ça l'important de se questionner puis de
vivre des expériences qui sont
significatives pour toi. C'est ce qu'on
va voir aujourd'hui. Mais que si tu
prends pas le temps de te questionner
régulièrement, ben tu vas tomber dans
l'entrep psychique puis tu vas juste
dériver sur plein de choses qui vont
faire que tu vas perdre ta vingtaine, tu
vas perdre ta trentaine, tu vas perdre
ta quarantaine, ta cinquantaine parce
que tu vas pas te questionner sur
vraiment toi c'est quoi qui t'allume
dans vie. Qu'est-ce que je vais faire
pour découvrir ce qui m'allume dans vie
?
Par la suite, les algorithmes tont
sublés. Donc TikTok, reals, la pointe,
tout ça, c'est bâti pour maximiser ta
dérive mentale. Parce que plus tu passes
de temps sur ces applications là,
plus les autres font de l'argent puis
ils veulent t'attirer le plus longtemps
possible sur leur plateforme. Donc vont
tout faire pour t'attirer en connaissant
justement que tu es attiré vers quoi
naturellement. Donc tout ce qui est euh
qui va faire de la dopamine rapide, mais
ils vont utiliser ces plateformes. Ces
perform vont utiliser ça pour
te focus toi te donner juste du stock
qui t'allume fait que si toi madame
c'est les filles ben l'algorithme va se
spotter que toi tu aimes ça les filles
puis ils vont juste te donner ça fait
naturellement tu vas être
automatiquement
tu vas dériver vers cette tu vas dériver
vers ta faiblesse en gu puis
l'algorithme va t'alimenter avec ça puis
tu vas perdre du temps, tu vas pas te
questionner vraiment puis ça va être
beaucoup plus facile. Je veux dire ta
vie beaucoup je c'est beaucoup plus
facile de te laisser dériver comme ça.
Je veux dire c'est des algorithmes qui
ont pensé pour ça. Tu sais fait que
c'est beaucoup plus facile de dériver
là-dedans. Mais c'est de te questionner
à OK, qu'est-ce que je veux vraiment ?
Puis tu es pas faible, tu es juste
ciblé. La différence change tout dans la
façon dont tu vas réagir. Donc tu es pas
faible, tu es tu es pas tu te laisses
pas dériver naturellement. C'est juste
que tu es ciblé, tu es comme tu es le
produit de tout ce qui est euh la
culture de consommation, le marketing,
tout ça est fait pour que tu dérives.
Mais c'est juste que tu dois prendre le
temps de te contrôler pour savoir c'est
quoi tu veux faire dans vie pour pas te
ramasser à 50 ans. Puis là tu commences
à vivre puis là tu vas commencer à
prendre des choix pour toi. Mais que
dans ta vingtaine tu commences à faire
des choix pour toi.
Donc on parlait de 10 décisions, je les
ai séparé en différentes sections. Puis
la première c'est dans ta vingtaine, tu
dois déblayer le terrain en premier.
Donc enlever le premier et la première
chose c'est coupe les distractions. Pas
parce que tu es faible parce que tu es
ciblé réseau, notification dopamine
rapide. Donc tout ce qui est
distraction,
tu peux y aller une partie de fun dans
ta vie. C'est juste que d'être conscient
au moins tu as des distractions qui te
permettent pas d'avancer vers vraiment
qui tu es. Fait distraction, tout ce qui
est réseaux sociaux, euh tout ce qui est
même la musique, c'est distraction, ça
te permet pas de garder une clarté
mentale pour penser à vraiment ce que tu
veux faire dans ta vie. Tu es tout le
temps surstimulé. Donc est-ce que couper
au maximum les distractions qui sont
inutiles fait euh musique euh tout ce
qui est Netflix tout ça c'est correct
une fois de temps en temps mais de pas
te laisser constamment stimuler puis
constamment distrait
fa musique Netflix euh tout ce qui est
euh ben il y en a plein qui vont être
partis sur les filles puis tout puis qui
ça va être genre leur quête ça va être
de de rener plein de filles puis tout
des dettes puis tout puis d'enchaîn
traîner puis tu sais ça c'est tout des
distractions qui vont prendre toute
l'espace dans ta tête. L'objectif c'est
de réduire ces distractions là ou au
moins de se rendre compte que c'est des
distractions puis que quand tu te
laisses distraire c'est conscient c'est
pas inconscient tu sais pas subir ça.
Donc arrêter la musique en continue.
Donc il y en a plein qui vont écouter de
la musique là dans leur char au travail
dans leur transport
à maison pendant qu' font à vaisselle
pendant qu'il marchent. Ils vont tout le
temps être stimulés par de la musique
par qu' ont pas la ils ont pas le le le
des moments pour réfléchir à qui qu'ils
sont par qu'est-ce qu'il veulent faire.
Ton cerveau génère jamais ses propres
pensées si tu as toujours quelque chose
dans tes oreilles. Tu vas juste tout le
temps distrait par les paroles de ta
chanson, le beat, les choses. Puis tu
vas pas être focus sur peut-être tes
propres pensées, ce qui ce qui t'allume
vraiment, ce qui t'anime, ce que tu es
bon, vers quoi tu es tendu d'aller vers
stop la pointe. Ça aussi c'est c'est
c'est il y a pas de moral, c'est du
conditionnement. tu recopes ton système
de récompense. Ça c'est vraiment une
manière de se récompenser naturellement,
facilement.
C'est écouter de la pointe. Ça c'est
vraiment une des des pires choses. Ça te
donne panine à fond sans faire d'effort.
Donc c'est vraiment c'est dégueulasse
comment ça te détruit ton cerveau puis
comment ça te conditionne, ça te cr des
addictions puis tu as pas une clarté
mentale après ça. Tu sais si tu écoutes
à chaque jour de la pointe, c'est sûr
que dans ton dans ta clarté mentale tu
es pas clair tu sais. Je veux dire, tu
vas penser à ça, tu vas être distrait
sur les réseaux sociaux, tu vas être
plus porté à euh regarder euh les filles
sur dans ta vie de tous les jours, tu
vas être plus porté à tu sais fait c'est
comme continuellement des choses comme
ça qui vont faire que tu es pas clair
dans ta tête puis dans ta ving c'est
super important de te questionner pour
avoir du temps pour te questionner pour
avoir une clarté mentale où c'est que tu
t'en vas dans la vie.
Donc l'entreprise l'entropie réactif
donc c'est là qui va être vraiment plus
la dopamine rapide, les pent dispersé la
vie selon la norme. Donc tu vas rentrer
dans la rat race, tu vas embarquer dans
la culture, tu vas embarquer dans euh
dans ce que la société veut t'embarquer.
Mais la société va va t'embarquer
naturellement. Tu embarqué dans la
norme, tu vas embarquer dans le average,
tu embarqué comme tout le monde fait ça
fait que je vais faire ça. Tu vas pas te
questionner à qu'est-ce que moi je veux
faire vraiment ? Tu dois naturellement
faire tout le monde fait ça fait il m'
fa m'avoiris
mais l'objectif c'est vraiment d'aller
dans l'ordre conscient plus intentionnel
donc tuir une attention qui est dirigée
énergie focalisée vis selon tes valeurs
à toi tu vas t'avoir questionné fait tu
vas pouvoir savoir c'est qu'est-ce que
tu veux réellement dans vie donc c'est
vers là qu'on veut tendre
par la suite la deè partie c'est rempl
le vide avec du réel donc on a fait
ménage on dans qu'est-ce qu'on va mettre
à la place de ce ménage
Lis des livres, des années de pensée dis
pour toi, densité impossible à trouver
sur les réseaux. Donc des livres, allez
va voir c'est quoi les livres que le
monde il lisent. Je vais faire une vidéo
d'ailleurs là-dessus euh
dans les prochaines vidéos là sur les
livres que je trouve qu' sont super
importants à lire dans sa vingtaine.
Mais l des livres apprend même sur
YouTube, il y a tellement de sources de
d'apprentissage que tu peux avoir. Va
lire va lire sur des sujets qui
t'intéressent des sujets qui
t'intéressent même pas même peut-être je
sais pas si tuas des je sais pas moi.
Bah sûr qu'idéalement c'est des affaires
qui qui t'intéressent. Non non, c'est
sûr que c'est des affaires qui
t'intéressent. Euh mais euh mais juste
lis, apprends que ce soit par des
podcasts, ça soit par des vidéos
YouTube, que ça soit par des livres,
apprends des choses. Puis les livres
c'est choses de la meilleure manière
parce que dis-toi que c'est il y a un
autre un autre concept de comment
choisir ce livre. Ça pas parler fois
mais des livres qui ont toffé dans le
temps là ça montre qu'il y a vraiment de
la valeur. le livre il a resté dans le
temps pendant 20 ans de temps puis il
est encore à toi accessible en ce moment
puis il se vend chez Renaubré Archambau
là imagine la valeur que ce livre là a
si il y a 20 ans dans le temps si tu ans
pense à ça c'est des pensées de
quelqu'un
qui qui a mis ça sur l'écrit puis si ces
pensées il ont resté dans le temps pour
se rendre à toi
ben ça montre à quel point ce livreel là
il y a de la valeur réelle puis même
Encore en 2026, il y a la valeur réelle.
Fait l des livres euh teste plein de
choses. Ce que tu recherches, non, ce
que tu cherches, c'est pas une passion,
c'est des données sur toi-même. Va
chercher de la data. va chercher la data
sur toi-même, va chercher le tu sais va
sortir de ta zone de confort. C'est
Lucas Off qui disait ça c'est un un
autre youtubeur euh français qui parlait
de vivre à sa limite. Va vivre à ta
limite de ta vingtaine. Dans ta
vingtaine va vivre à ta limite tout le
temps. Va reper tes limites pour voir
c'est où que tu peux aller. C'est où que
tu es inconfortable, c'est où que tu te
sens épanoui. C'est mais c'est en cette
limite là en faisant des choses
différentes que là tu vas apprendre sur
toi-même.
Sois curieux à fond. C'est l'autre
point. La curiosité, c'est une entropie
inversée. Tu diriges ton attention vers
toi-même. Tu vas aller t'intriguer aux
choses autour de toi. Tu vas apprendre
puis en même temps d'apprendre sur des
choses différentes sur des
du monde qui t'entoure. Tu vas apprendre
sur toi-même sur qu'est-ce que tu aimes.
Super intéressant. ça peut t'ouvrir des
portes. Donc tout ça là, ça va amener un
effet de levier sur le long terme qui
est immense parce que tu vas apprendre
des skills, des compétences puis ces
compétenceslà ils sont ils vont se
multiplier entre elles
puis ça va faire que tu te donner une
personne qui est complètement
différente. Tu lis à chaque jour, c'est
euh
Elliot Muni qui disait que lui qui
faisait qu'est-ce qu'il faisait c'est
non même pas en tout cas peu importe
dans le livre Miracle Morning en tout
cas peu importe il disait qu'il lit deux
pages par soir minimum deux pages.
Pourquoi deux pages ? Parce que deux
pages, c'est le temps que ça prend pour
te mettre dans le bain de du livre. Puis
ça arrive extrêmement souvent que tu vas
lire deux pages. Finalement, tu vas une
3è, une 4è, une 5è, finalement, tu vas
10. Puis si à chaque jour tu lis deux
pages qui est le temps nécessaire pour
te mettre dans le bon, ben à chaque
fois, tu vas peut-être déborder un peu
puis finalement tu vas te 20 pages par
jour mais que tu t'es mis un deux pages
minimum. Fa que si une fois une fois tu
es tu es fatigué, ben tu vas lire quand
même tes deux pages puis tu vas
t'arrêter à deux mais d'autres fois que
tu vas continuer. Donc un autre petit
truc
euh par la suite la deuxième section
c'est la compétence la plus
sous-estimée.
C'est pas une compétence mais voyager
solo. Sincèrement c'est insane. Moi je
l'ai fait. Je suis parti en Amérique
centrale pendant 2 mois et demi. C'est
formidable ou à quel point tu vis des
expériences qui sont condensées, qui
sont euh différente, que tu rencontres
énormément de gens, tu vis des
inconforts, euh tu vas tu vas apprendre
énormément sur toi. C'est fantastique.
comme si tu vis 20 ans d'expérience mais
tu lui consenses en 2 mois et demi parce
que tu vois tu es dans tu es pas chez
vous, tu es pas avec des gens que tu
connais, tu es dans un environnement
différent à chaque jour puis tu vis des
choses différentes à chaque jour pu là
tu apprends à te gérer, tu apprends à
voir c'est quoi tes tes tes processus
mentaux, c'est quoi tes patterns,
comment gérer ces patterns là, comment
les analyser puis comment évoluer au
travers de ça fait quand tu arriv dans
ta vie normale
m tu es tu es complèement différent. Tu
es plus le même la même personne. 8 pose
des relations romantiques. Sincèrement
pour dans ta vingtaine au moins essaie 3
à 6 mois essaie de être seul. Il y en a
qui vont enchaîner les relations
amoureuses là de de de secondaire
jusqu'à toute leur reste de leur vie.
Ils vont tout le temps les enchaîner qui
vont euh passer de
ils vont une relation de 2 3 ans, ils
vont après ça ils vont arrêter là 1 mois
de mois plus tard bom sont encore en
relation pendant un autre 2 3 ans puis
ils vont tout le temps enchaîner comme
ça puis ils vont jamais être seuls avec
eux-même seul avec leur pensées
fait juste de prendre un moment que tu
es seul que tu es tuas plus de temps
pour toi-même parce qu'il y en a souvent
qui vont justement quand ils sont en
couple toutes les choses toutes les le
temps qu'ils ont
qui pourrait être seul, ils vont le
faire avec leur avec leur leur blonde
leur ch par exemple aller prendre une
marche, ils vont prendre une marche avec
leur ch avec leur blonde.
Il y a une journée qui sont tout seul,
ben ils vont prendre cette journéel puis
il vont faire "Ah qu'est-ce que tu es ?"
Bon, on va être ensemble tout le temps
comme ça. Mais c'est les moments que que
tu es seul, c'est là que tu que tu vas
réfléchir à à qui tu es d'expérimenter
des choses à apprendre. C'est que tu vas
lire des livres, c'est là que tu vas
prendre des marches pour réfléchir, tu
vas méditer et cetera. Donc sont super
importantes. Donc au moins fait un 3 à 6
mois seul. Ça fait
quitte pas ta bl demain matin pour à
cause de ces vidéos là mais réfléchis à
ça next time que peut-être que tu vas
être célibataire ou peu importe que
c'est good d'être célibataire pendant
quelques mois. C'est pas loser p tout p
pas tout p pas tout p pas tout
puis tu connais jamais tes vrais besoins
tant que tu es pas seul assez longtemps.
C'est quand tu es seul longtemps que tu
v réaliser finalement c'est quoi tout tu
as besoin réellement puis tes relations
ameuses plus tard vont être beaucoup
plus
saines profonde parce que tu sais
réellement qui tu es.
Lorsque l'on perd la capacité à être
seul on se laisse emporter par la foule.
Donc tu vas te laisser emporter par
c'est quoi le average fait ? C'est quoi
la moyenne fond ? Je vais embarquer
là-dedans puis je vais suivre ça. Tandis
que si tu es seul assez longtemps pour
te questionner assez longtemps sur
toi-même, c'est là que tu prends des
décisions pour toi.
Puis euh
j'ai rien
si tu commences maintenant à 30 ans, tu
as 30 ans de plus en alignement avec qui
tu es vraiment. Young a découvert que
les gens commencent à se connaître à 50
ans. Toi, tu as 20, si toi tu as 20 ans
en live, la fenêtre est encore ouverte.
Si tu as 20 ans en ce moment puis
tuappliques ce que tu as dans cette
vidéolà
à chaque jour, tu essayes de d'alimenter
ça, de de d'apprendre à te connaître, tu
coupes les distractions, tu remplis les
distractions avec des choses qui font du
sens, qui apprennent à te connaître, qui
qui font que tu apprennes à te
connaître, ben
ça sera pas à 50 ans que tu vas tu que
tu vas tu vas te connaître réellement.
Ça va peut-être plus être à 30 35
peut-être puis ta vie va être
complètement différente. Si à 30 35
tu t'apprends, tu te connais beaucoup
plus, ben toutes tes choix de ta vie
vont ils vont être différents parce que
tu vas dire non aux choses qui ne te
plaît pas, tu vas dire oui, tu vas
embarquer, tu vas pousser, tu vas
prendre plus de risque parce que tu sais
c'est ça que tu veux, c'est ça que tu v
si tu sais pas tu vas être mou, tu vas
te plier, tu vas fiter dans le moule.
Donc super important.
Puis les derniers points, cartographie
qui tu es vraiment.
Le point c'est faire passant. Je sais
pas si vous connaissez pas, on a fait on
a fait on a parlé à quelques vidéos mais
c'est 10 jours de silence total. Pas de
téléphone, pas de musique, pas de
conversation. Tu mettais 10h par jour
pendant 10 jours. Tu mettis 100 he pu tu
es seul. Le seul endroit où l'ego peut
pas se cacher, c'est là. Donc tu vas
être face à face avec toi-même, face à
ton ego, puis tu vas vraiment te poser
des vraies questions. Tu vas apprendre à
apprendre c'est quoi qui se passe dans
ta tête puis qu'est-ce que tu veux pour
le futur
puis par la suite éclore ton côté
spirituel. C'est quoi tu crois ? C'est
quoi ta ta foi ? C'est quoi qu'est-ce
que tu veux dans vie ? Pourquoi tu es à
terre ? Tu sais peu importe la forme,
comprends qui tu es. Pourquoi tu es là ?
C'est ça le spirituel. Tout le monde
pense que spirituel c'est avec des
roches avec des affaires puis de en
ligement de la lune puis tu sais des
affaires bien tu sais funky tu sais qui
associ spirituel à funky spécial avec
des roches puis des des fortes tu sais
mais au final spirituel c'est juste
comprends tu es qui toi pourquoi tu es
ça à terre
c'est pas de la faiblesse c'est juste la
cartographie intérieure de comprendre tu
es qui toi
pour que tu deviennes le plus singulier
possible, tu deviennes toi.
Donc l'action de la semaine 24 he
essayie d'avoir 24 he sans musique sans
réseau, sans scroll puis note ce qui
fait du journaling. Questionne-toi. OK.
Qui que je suis ? Je veux faire quoi
dans vie ? C'est sûr c'est t ça va être
t ça. Des questionnements qui vont être
long, ça va être mais c'est super
pertinent. Ça va t'apporter énormément
de valeur pour toutes tes décisions,
tout ton chemin de vie qui en ligne vers
toi dans les prochaines années puis le
reste de ta vie. Donc
si tu aimé ça like puis commente ça
quelqu'un commente une vidéo ça serait
ça serait nice juste
je sais pas qu'est-ce que tu as appris
genre je sais plus qu' a pas en ce
moment il y a pas grand monde qui écoute
mes vidéos mais
quelqu'un commente ça serait vraiment
cool.
En tout cas, salut.